ce soir avec nous à notre panel hélène
buzzetti michel serrault g et le
ferrandez bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir
bonjour on va commencer par se plaint de
monsieur diby ministre de la santé qui
est venue de l'expliquer en direct en
tout début d'émission petit clip ici
petit extrait de l'esprit de ce plan là
on l'écouté c'est fini les attentes il
faut passer à l'action et la pandémie
nous oblige de le faire les québécois
méritent mieux je pense que si on
travaille tout le monde ensemble
non seulement dans les prochaines mois
mais dans les prochaines années on sera
capable de livrer la marchandise
un engagement on aura le courage de
faire les bonnes actions
bon vous avez tous plusieurs années
d'expérience derrière vous vous en avez
vu passer des rapports des promesses
électorales des plans d'un bond de la
santé avait déjà commencé avec vous
cette fois ci ce qui ne garantit que ce
serait la bonne mais peut-être le fait
que si pas spectaculaires comme rapport
comme comme proposition plus tôt on ne
promet pas de grandes mesures on arrive
plus tôt avec des choses très
circonscrites qu'on pourrait presque
dire presque dans des tailles
bureaucratique a remplacé lui ligne de
fax n'est pas mal de choses comme ça et
peut-être que c'est là la solution
justement des changements qui ne sont
pas spectaculaires mais qui pourrait
apporter une modification à long terme
évidemment ces fameux garde ses guichets
une équipe au pouvoir pour accéder à des
professionnels c'est une petite
révolution qu'on nous annonce qui
m'apparaît intéressante cependant moi je
vois un risque si ça ne tenait pas
combiner avec un dossier informatisé
unique par patient on va se retrouver
peut-être dans quelques années avec une
génération de patients orphelins ou de
patients itinérant qui va voir comme ça
déboule leur dossier médical un petit
peu partout répartis en toutes sortes de
deux spécialistes et cela me semble t'il
qu'à long terme ça pourrait présenter un
risque s'il n'y a pas cette cette
concentration du dossier médical donc un
gros défi de mise à jour informatique de
du mental si on sait d'organisation le
vraiment dont on parle ici michel vous
en avez vu passer plus que plan de
réforme de la santé celui là est ce qui
vous semble mais comme il est dit
suffisamment réaliste pour dire qu'il ya
une chance d'être appliquée
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya aussi
ces apports de réingénierie du système
de leurs fondations etc non il y avoit 6
et 10 depuis plusieurs années voici ce
que on va prendre là bas c'est une bonne
nouvelle
la moins bonne ou celle où ça risquent
d'achopper
d'une part il ya ce guichet unique à
chaque fois indiqué unix parce que ça
vous coupe la fonction publique ou
gouvernementales et deuxièmement ça
implique une augmentation de personnel
un portable et des mesures de rétention
du personnel ce qui va coûter très cher
alors est ce qu'ils sont capables
d'avoir le millier d'infirmières de plus
actionnaire capable d'avoir des
cas
on est en situation de pénurie de
personnel partout et la dureté du
travail on l'a vu dans des hôpitaux au
cours des derniers mois en particulier
c'est un travail très dur c'est pas
nécessairement de ce qu'est ce qui va
amener les gens dans ce secteur là même
si on abolit le temps je suis aux
interrogatoires et des choses comme ça
oui parce que ça c'est un des grands
défis c'est ce que faisait mine est
d'ailleurs de rendre ce secteur dans le
secteur de la santé attrayant
manifestement il ya une grande côte à
remonter le second poteau de table
d'abord sur est ce que cette fois c'est
la bonne en pensez quoi vous
il ya deux gros jeu de dominos dada le
plein de monsieur diby premier c'est si
les pièces tombent depuis son mobile
domino suivant il va avoir gagné les
pièces tombent à plat les autres pièces
s'engage pas il va avoir perdu premier
jeu de dominos ou les infirmières ils
confondent engager 1000 pour qu'elle
puisse remplacer les infirmières
lorsqu'elle est de l'absence où il ya
beaucoup d'absentéisme chez des
infirmières donc si on a des éphémères
pour les remplacer il n'y aura pas de
temps supplémentaire obligatoire bingo
il en va retenir plus éphémère deuxième
chose sont de plus d'infirmières on
ouvre 2010 en construire de nouveaux il
est prévu d'en construire de nouveaux
pour envoyer encore 2 en 2010 mais les
deux premiers mais lee on sent capable
de les ouvrir juste en augmentant le
nombre des chômeurs parce que ces délits
qu'on en a déjà mais qui ne sont pas
occupés et l'autre ce qu'on fait à ce
moment là c'est qu'on en voit beaucoup
de gens qui sont dans les urgences vers
des étages supérieurs est ce ça libère
beaucoup de travail pour les infirmières
aussi alors c'est un premier jeu de
dominos deuxième jeu de dominos les
médecins si on filtre les appels par
exemple avec le système du bas saint
laurent où on dit bombe et vous vous
avez juste besoin de conditions de vol
de votre prescription vous avez besoin
de tout voir côté rap et vous un
ergothérapeute et bien il ya moins de
travail qui arrivèrent les médecins on
en voit aussi des corps vers le privé il
ya moins de travail tarifaire les
métiers questionnant le public et donc
la pression de la loi 11 qui dit on va
aller prendre les patients orphelins par
voilier capturé au niveau des jmf avant
d envoyer vers les urgences tous ces
dominos là doivent fonctionner c'est un
gros risque mais c'est possible oui
c'est un gros risque quand même et le
temps pour le faire en fait cela fait de
la cession d'ici la campagne électorale
c'est assez court à monsieur dubé avait
l'ambition que la moitié des patients
orphelins ils sont autour d'un million
actuellement et accès à ce service de
première ligne grâce à ce guichet d'ici
la fin de l'été ce délai qui est quand
même assez court mais il ya aussi une
sorte de réforme m dans la philosophie
parce qu'ils vendent ce qui était vendu
au départ dans la dernière campagne
électorale c'était un médecin de famille
pour chaque québécois mais c'est pas ce
qu'on fait actuellement est-ce que ça va
passer auprès de la population mais
c'est justement ce que je reviens ce que
je disais tout à l'heure justement on de
transformer la promesse en disant au
départ un médecin de famille par
québécois a maintenant un québécois pour
une ligne guichet unique qui pour lui
dire où aller alors la première c'est le
seul matt et métamorphose dans un court
laps de temps à court terme c'est
vraiment ça se reprendra bienfaiteur
parce que la plupart des gens qui
veulent être traités vont aimer cette
pouvoir comme ça allait vers le bon
spécialiste mais c'est si à long terme
on garde ça et qu'on abandonne
finalement cette idée d'avoir un médecin
de famille pour chaque québécois de
façon à ce qu'ils soient suivis de
manière par c'est moi le mot holistique
dans son lancement et c'est là qu'à long
terme les problèmes vont se manifester
parce que les gens n'auront pas de suivi
global ils vont juste comme ça allait à
la pièce phare traité lors leurs
problèmes ouais vous êtes d'accord avec
ce look ça représente parce que j'ose
dire il faut que les gens embarquent là
dedans quand vous voulez voir un médecin
voudrait pas voir un ambulancier par
exemple vous voulez pas voir un
pharmacien
tout à fait et la médecine holistique
des crimes allant busuttil ça fait ses
preuves notamment à l'époque s'il ya des
personnes qui en ont besoin d'avoir un
suivi c'est à dire que elles vont
revenir de façon courante quotidienne
presque parfois parce qu'elles ont des
douleurs mais le médecin déjà rencontré
des gens on sait qu'on peut pas résoudre
cette douleur l'oeuf elle supportait pas
leur médication il faut encadrer de
certains patients de façon ferme pas
juste les mettre en lien reckoning
téléphonique ça ne peut pas fonctionner
pour tout le monde mais j'en connais pas
mal de santé mentale et j'en connais mal
a dit prôner des personnes âgées vous
étiez parfaitement raison non là on
qu'on voyait les gens dans la salle ont
été entendues applaudir après le point
de presse on était dans un hôpital pour
le point de presse en question donc
avait beaucoup de gens qui travaillent
dans le domaine hospitalier fameux
docteur marc qui étaient là plutôt
d'accord plutôt positif avec ce plan là
mais l'absence de la fiq c'est quand
même une grosse pièce quand vous parlez
les deux minots l'ucl c'en est tout un
c'est plus que domine on les fixe elles
sont indispensables les infirmières et
les infirmiers michel là dessus on sent
que ça va être un gros défi à monsieur
monsieur dubé veut pas prendre les gens
de façon frontale actuellement ils
cherchent des collaborations il cherche
des entendants dans l'impression ça sera
pas facile avec la fiq
non pour deux raisons d'abord parce
qu'il a fait qu'est vraiment la première
ligne de touche et de tout réseau et
deuxièmement parce qu'on a vu une
certaine radicalisation de la direction
de la fuite depuis quelques mois qui est
bien compréhensible parce que ils sont
fait faire des promesses souvent frr qui
sont en emploi étaient tenues sous pas
alors je raconterai pas trop
d'importance au fait qu'ils n'étaient
pas là aujourd'hui mais il va falloir
que le gouvernement
la reconnaissent la difficulté de ce
travail là quelle qu'elle soit mieux
compenser et
la première chose à faire c'est parce
que trois
ce qui est un peu le début de tout l'est
du puits mais ça lui d'être un défi
insurmontable d'arrêter le temps
supplémentaire obligatoire on a toujours
l'impression qu'on est devant le fou la
poule parce que si on l'arrête on fait
quoi on peut pas laisser le patient tout
seul il s'accroche du recrutement mais
on a du mal à recruter justement parce
qu'on n'est pas de qualité de vie à
cause du temps supplémentaire
obligatoire j'ai toujours du mal à boire
par quelle porte de sortie encore un
seul
sait ce serait pas miraculeux sur ce
circuit hellip bon le temps ce matin
obligatoire a été réduit jusqu'à 1 - 2 1
pour ça
d'abord dans des projets où on travaille
avec l'horaire 12 12 12 encore là ça
règle pas tous les problèmes
12h02 jours 12 heures de soirées privées
des horaires comme ça non plus 20 non
c'est pas tout le monde mais si on fait
de l'autogestion comme ça a été fait à
la malbaie ras du poteau gestion plus
tard plus dos 12-12 s'adonne semble-t-il
des bons résultats alors il ya
possibilité ça existe ça s'est fait de
réduire
bon on va écouter maintenant les
réactions des oppositions peut-être un
petit peu attendu on les écoute
aujourd'hui si vous n'avez pas de
médecin de famille chez vous là on vous
dit que vous n'en aurez pas plus avec la
cac ce pour moi c'est la preuve que
c'est un programme électoral qui sont en
train de tester à quelques mois des
élections le constat c'est que ce n'est
pas un plan gouvernemental c'est un
programme électoral
hélène est ce que
c'est à dire que le ministre ait donné
quand même plusieurs années jusqu'en
2025 là on a une élection que s'en vient
cet automne est ce que tout ça va pas se
transformer en promesses électorales ben
oui peut-être en même temps comme je
vous disais il ya pas de grands feux
d'artifice dans cette annonce donc on
verra cet automne si pour accompagner
cette vision qu'on nous a présenté
aujourd'hui il y aura des annonces de
financement qui le deviendront des
promesses électorales
mais quand même il faut remarquer qu'il
ya un fossé aujourd'hui entre les
critiques systématiques 6 plaisir de
l'opposition qui bosse si son rôle
d'être opposés et d'autre part comme le
mentionnait michel le fait que les la
plupart des corps de métiers dans you
médicales ont bien accueilli la réforme
aujourd'hui moi c'est ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé le fait qu'il y avait
une quasi unanimité
positive envers ce qu'annonçait le
gouvernement ce qui m'amène à peut-être
prendre avec un plus gros grain de sel
que d'habitude les critiques de
l'opposition et puis reste mais celle
aussi on se rappelle les dernières
promesses électorales de la campagne
électorale précédant mais reste quand
les deux il ya eu ce qui s'appelle une
pandémie alors nécessairement comment
dire ça dans ce domaine il ya quand même
des raisons pour lesquelles il ya des
choses qui aurait dû être fait qui ont
peu été fait jusqu'à maintenant et on
est devenu très critique envers le
système de santé rappelons-nous le que
parfois on nous expliquait qu'on faisait
déconfinement parce qu'il fallait
protéger justement le système de santé
cela dit je pense que la réaction
positive des gens dans la salle qui
applaudit tout ça je pense qu'il y
aurait dans le réseau de la sapn général
et et même chez les infirmes et a même
si la direction syndicale n'est
peut-être pas de ce côté là encore est
une espèce de deux volontés que ça
marche et ce qui me tue dubé mène par sa
personnalité est quelqu'un qui cliquent
équipe qui est pas car ça qui essaie
d'être sur les algues et cette idée là
de dire je ferai pas la 9e réforme du
pays pour tout changer dans le système
ja on va prendre des choses qui sont
déjà là on a déjà vu que ces élections a
d'autres apports varier d appliquer pour
une fois je pense que les gens n'étaient
pas prêts à une grande réforme à la base
de connaissances et quand j'arrive sur
la fondation d'ailleurs il a enlevé le
mou refondation anzin annoncé on
applique un plein mais on referme plus
rien
exactement
alors fait du sujet on va pas ça le
sujet maintenant parce qu'il y avait
deux bronzes annonce aujourd'hui avec ce
plan de santé mais il y avait aussi ce
plan de réduction des ges au canada on
est côté c'est justin trudeau
c'est un plan ambitieux et responsable
ce plan historique nous permettre de
réduire nos émissions de 40% d'ici 2030
par rapport aux niveaux de 2005 et de
réaliser nos objectifs
2 khalid et carbone d'ici 2050
la cij a commencé avec voulu que
généralement vos rêves vos réactions
face à ce plan
le plan ainsi de ménager la chèvre et le
chou c'est à dire on va continuer de
produire du pétrole et du gaz au même
rythme où on en produit actuellement et
même augmenté et on va reporter le plus
tard possible la réduction des
ges qui sont liées au transport or il ya
trois possibilités de réduire
notre empreinte carbone le pétrole
l'électricité le transport la production
d'électricité et de transport si deux de
ces trois là sont reportés et amoindri
j'ai des doutes mais avec cette idée
qu'on va varier justement on va y aller
par secteur parce que ce qu'on demande
finalement aux secteurs pétrolier et
gazier c'est moins lourd c'est moins
imposant que ce qu'on demande à d'autres
secteurs en un tableau d'ailleurs qu'on
peut vous montrer le clic manque
justement cette espèce de logique là
est-ce que avec le principe de base est
oui d'accord avec ce look oui tout à
fait par exemple dans les déchets une
bonne partie de des mesures doivent être
mises en place ont été mises en place
avec les plantations des services de
compostage dans l'église dans il reste
du travail à faire mais les déchets on
voit qu'il ya plus de notation possible
par l'agriculture il ya peu de guerre
afin 1% d'ici 2030 de toute manière il
ya une augmentation de la population qui
est prévu or c'est le pays qui reçoit le
plus d'immigrants au monde donc une
augmentation de la population une
augmentation de la production agricole
c'est normal qu'ils aient pas de
réduction les bâtiments ça va prendre du
temps qu'on reconstruit pas la totalité
de nos bâtiments à tous les cinq ans pas
comparer achètent nos voitures à tous
les cinq ans et c'est pour ça que les
débats il ya des domaines comme de
bâtiments qui vont lentement et domaines
comme le transport devrait arriver alors
c'est normal que ça soit avaria s'assoit
politesse variable notre réaction va
vous mais celle là dessus
beaucoup de scepticisme d'abord parce
qu'on désire jamais ap nono nous leurs
cibles de réduction des gaz à effet de
serre que les secteurs du pétrole et du
gaz a été celui que le moins bien
performé dans cette réduction là alors
que comment on peut passer
qu'avec des cibles pas trop contraignant
avec eux
il faut oublier 2036 la 8ème c'est
presque deux mecs et
c'est une grosse bouchée avalée
c'est très ambitieux 40% à 8
je me sens pas très à l'aise à dire ah
ils ont trouvé la formule pour pour
réussir cette fois ci alors que toutes
les autres fois ça marche avez-vous
autant de scepticisme et rennes
pas autant nom htc d'accord avec lui que
cette modulation par secteur elle est
totalement logique et elle s'explique
aussi parce qu'on veut être le plus
efficace possible on va faire les
mesures qui sont les plus susceptibles
de nous rapporter gros en termes de
réduction de ges je pense je pense par
exemple au secteur de l'électricité on
dit que les diminutions sont 2 88% le
chiffre paraît gros mais c'est parce
qu'il ya encore beaucoup de productions
et d'électricité au canada qui se fait
par la combustion du charbon une
substance extrêmement polluante
évidemment et c'est très fin très facile
en guillemets de faire une transition de
stress que vers le gaz naturel dont
certains diront c'est pas un gros gain
mais on gagne quand même 30 %
d'efficacité par rapport au charbon et
ça c'est une transition très très facile
à faire bref dans ce secteur là on peut
facilement transformer notre électricité
aller chercher des gros bien sûr la
question des transports lui qu'en raison
de mentionner diminution de 11% c'est
très peu les transports c'est une
contribution équivalente au pétrole
quant à notre bilan canaries alors on le
laisse un peu de peu de l'ours passez
moi l'expression aux automobilistes
l'actuel continuer à prendre leur
voiture mais clairement c'est que on
pense qu'à partir de 2030 on va
commencer vraiment à augmenter la vente
avec une obligation parce que séparées
avec le avec des obligations exactement
les véhicules électriques et donc on
pense qu'il va y avoir une courbe
exponentielle à partir de 2030 et que là
c'est le secteur des transports qui dans
la prochaine tranche de nous oublier une
autre obligation se fera le plus gros la
plus grosse part des diminutions bon
maintenant la réaction de monsieur singh
dans rappelons nous que tout récemment
les u17 entente qui nous ont un peu
surpris
mène entre le npd et le parti libéral
pour finalement avoir un gouvernement
stable on bascule le report en élections
afin la fin du mandat de monsieur
trudeau mais encore faut-il que le npd
soit satisfait de ce qu'on lui offre
mais ce signe réaction va l'écouter
le lean est écrit dans l'entente le fait
qu' on a une cible comme j'ai donné
d'éliminer les subventions pétrolière
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas dans
le l'annnonce du gouvernement on a le
droit on a la possibilité de retirer
notre appui mais j'ai confiance qu'on
peut utiliser cette entente pour faire
mieux pour les gens pour forcer le
mouvement des livres et les marchandises
michel qu'est ce qui veut dire monsieur
singh est ce qui est en train de vie
redevient faire plus wisques est en
train de dire mais là j'ai mis de l'eau
dans mon vin
il est entre les deux il est en train de
dire je suis pas très content de ce que
je vois en même temps j tigana cherche
un peu mais elle veut lui même si je
crois que ça me donne le droit de
martyrs et de le faire m mais je sais
moi sur ce fil de fer là pour les
prochaines années là il veut être partis
d'opposition
question de confiance et les questions
financières il va botter que le
gouvernement alors c'est le genre de
situation un peu inconfortable j'aime
pas ça mais c'est pas si mal qu'on va
entendre souvent d'abord devenu cours
des prochaines années alors parlons du
budget on a appris la date d'aujourd'hui
le 7 avril c'est madame pauline qui en a
parlé avec une question qu'on appelle
planté pendant deux questions vous vous
attendez à quoi hélène
bah écoutez je ne suis pas dans le
secret des dieux évidemment mais ce
qu'on regarde évidemment deux choses la
question des dépenses militaires est ce
qu est longuement de ronde en contexte
de le craint évidemment on va regarder
ça avec attentive avec attention mais
aussi
le budget répondront-ils aux attentes du
npd face à cette nouvelle arrivante qui
a été signée la semaine passée en
particulier la question des soins
dentaires l'entente dit que dès cette
année les soins dentaires pour les moins
de 12 ans devrait être couvert donc
c'est très très court comme échéancier
et ça évidemment c'est susceptible
d'ouvrir un front avec les provinces
notamment au québec où les soins
dentaires pour les jeunes de 10 ans et
moins sont couverts ou presque tous
couverts alors on peut imaginer que
québec va demander une compensation
droit de retrait avec compensation ils
savent à chicaner sur le montant
bref on va regarder si c'est la dame et
aussi la réaction des provinces à ça
parce que je suis pas certaine mois que
toutes les provinces sont enchantés à
cette idée d'élargir encore le le panier
de services de santé couvert le coup vos
attentes bon tu me donnes entente entre
5 et trudeau il était clair que c'était
les questions de santé et les questions
sociales qui prenait le haut du pavé
l'environnement pour monsieur 50 ajouté
mais c'était pas l'essentiel de sa de
l'entente alors il va faire très très
attention à ce que les soins dentaires
soit dans le prochain budget et
peut-être aussi d'assurance médicaments
c'est la première sur la deuxième chose
on est une inflation galopante
la troisième chose on a une 10 première
ministre est une boîte ce qui veut
dépenser dans
l'armée avec un projet de 9 milliards et
encore 9 milliards sont des dépenses
d'exploitation les deux gros projets
l'achat des avions f 35 19 milliards de
dollars et par la suite l'achat des deux
bateaux soit pour la garde nationale
soit pour le ministre de la défense de
80 milliards de dollars donc tout ça ça
me fait penser qu'il va y avoir un
énorme budget
oui les derniers mots là-dessus en moins
d'une minute michel
pour les canadiens ordinaires de la
création sais c'est pas des dépenses de
bateaux ses dépenses quotidiennes et il
va falloir aussi créé ce très attention
à ça parce que il ya plusieurs provinces
que ça avant l'élection bientôt ça
pourrait créer des frictions avec les
provinces ce budget là est vraiment trop
expansionniste pitre au trophée sioniste
oui et puis le test que ça représente
pour cette entente avec le npd
le test doit être permanent mais jeudi
le npd à la fin peut bien dire ce qu'ils
veulent ils ne peuvent qu à ce moment ci
se retirer de ce
livre on est obligé de trouver des bons
côtés même pas ce qu'ils aient moins
comme par exemple alors verra on verra
donc 7 avril on l'a tous noté de toute
façon on aura l'occasion d'en parler à
ce moment-là hélène michel le merci vous
de voir avec nous
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit